oui je n'avais pas du tout l'intention
de faire une déclaration
l'ava puisque vous me souhaiter je veux
bien vous dire quelques mots sur ce qui
a été fait ce qui se prépare alors pour
simplifier si vous le voulez bien je
prendrai les choses un peu dans l'ordre
chronologique
immédiatement après le vote à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai reçu le
président et des représentants de la
fédération nationale des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles il avait deux
préoccupations et sur les deux points je
leur ai répondu de façon je crois tout à
fait satisfaisante pour eux car c'est la
position du gouvernement ça consistait à
leur dire tout d'abord qu'à bruxelles le
gouvernement français serait d'une
extrême fermeté sur le marché commun
agricole son organisation et que par
conséquent il serait leur un désintérêt
l'agriculture française serait défendu
et défendu pied à pied
résolument et d'autre part que en ce qui
concerne les discussions qui vont
s'ouvrir un peu partout à la suite de la
crise et que sociale que nous
connaissons les agriculteurs et leurs
représentants seraient évidemment
associé à tous qu'ils consommeraient les
problèmes économiques généraux et tous
ceux qui auraient une incidence sur
l'agriculture dans la journée d'hier
j'ai commencéà également à penser au
problème de la réforme de l'éducation
nationale mais je n'en dirai pas plus
pour aujourd'hui sinon qu'il est
probable que dans les jours prochains
je recevrai la fédération de l'éducation
nationale
c'est en effet le problème social actuel
qui était au premier plan de mes
préoccupations et donc mes occupations
j'ai eu des entretiens dès hier ce matin
encore avec monsieur le ministre
l'économie et des finances avec monsieur
mise affaires sociales avec le
secrétaire d'état à l'emploi
j'en aurai cet après midi
avec les mets mais également avec tous
les ministres qui se veut responsable
des grands services publics pour faire
le tour des problèmes qui se posent et
pour fixer moi même sur les directions
dans lesquelles nous pourrions trouver
des solutions en face des revendications
qui sont présentes
c'est à la suite de ce premier examen et
avant les examens approfondis de cet
après midi qu'elle a été publié le
communiqué que vous connaissez et par
lequel toutes les organisations
syndicales et patronales sont convoqué
pour demain au ministère des affaires
sociales à l'ancien ministère du travail
qu'attendez-vous de cette réunion de
demain ce premier mise
écoutez le communiqué ne dit je souhaite
que nous aurons au moins un accord sur
la suite des discussions il est bien
évident que nous n'allons pas résoudre
tous les problèmes et toutes les
questions dans la journée de demain mais
je tiens je souhaite et je souhaite
fermement et j'ajoute j'espère aboutir à
un accord sur la suite des discussions
c'est à dire montrer que la négociation
s'engage et s'engage avec une certaine
volonté d'aboutir